é bom contar uma história pra vocês que
começou no ano de 1961 na história de
vida não tenho só 28 anos mas 61 o então
presidente norte americano john kenneth
veio a público na tv e fez um
compromisso ele prometeu que até o final
daquela década
o homem chega pisar na lua
pensando nessa história na forma como
quem devia público se comprometeu em
fazer algo que jamais tinha sido feito
eu comecei a refletir sobre as causas e
o peso que a gente dá pra casa cada casa
que a gente acredita que o porquê que um
chefe de estado
um líder como kennedy não venha público
também com a mesma energia mesmo senso
de comprometimento para resolver
problemas sociais como a gente tem o
caso do lixo do da mobilidade urbana o
problema da educação é uma das doenças
crônicas não transmissíveis por exemplo
eu comecei a pensar sobre o que me faria
ea público e fazer o compromisso de
passar os próximos cinco dez 20 anos
trabalhando a minha vida minha energia
o meu tempo e conhecimento para resolver
um problema social de verdade e essa
reflexão a me levou a perceber que
existe uma desconexão muito grande entre
o que eu fazia no meu dia a dia na época
em que comecei a pensar nessas coisas
trabalhava numa empresa grande no
background em marketing gestão de
projetos estão na área de administração
e negócios e eu percebi essa desconexão
entre as coisas que eu fazia no meu dia
a dia ea a as causas que eu mesmo
reconhecia como algo que eu gostaria de
trabalhar para ajudar a resolver
e foi nessa busca que eu descobrir que
existe um nome porque eu queria fazer
uma carreira empreendedorismo social e
comecei a buscar referências na
literatura descobrindo em empresas
organizações de trabalho incentivando o
fomento ao empreendedorismo social que
basicamente é a combinação da engrenagem
de um de um negócio tradicional que visa
o lucro com a missão social de resolver
problemas reais principalmente da base
da pirâmide e eu descobrir
que é acontecer um evento chamado chata
porque de favela foi o primeiro já a
política quem conhece um formato onde
uma imersão durante o final de semana
onde empreendedores entusiastas de
empreendedorismo se reúnem para
trabalhar em soluções que podem resolver
problemas reais das pessoas
eu espero que esse evento acontece no
morro da providência uma favela no rio
de janeiro atrás da central do brasil
que é um lugar histórico onde viu
machado de assis e é a primeira favela
do brasil de verdade e eu tive lá nesse
evento e foi uma experiência
transformadora pra mim eu conheci vários
livros comentários pessoas da própria
comunidade podia me relacionar mais com
a realidade dos problemas que a base da
pirâmide promete pessoas que vivem em
favelas em áreas remotas e de difícil
acesso no brasil e eu percebi que
existiam ali problemas que problemas
graves que todo todos nós passamos mas
que para determinadas populações são
ainda mais críticos
um deles é o da saúde ela conhece um
jovem amputado e por conta daquele
contexto de vulnerabilidade social
imaginei logo que era algum problema
relacionado à violência
na verdade eu descobri que aquele jovem
perdeu parte da perna por conta do
diabetes o diabetes tipo 2 por exemplo é
evitável e às vezes até reversível com
um diagnóstico precoce e mudanças de
hábito foi que o primeiro click eu
pensei que eu posso fazer com a minha
ainda pouco mais alguma experiência
tecnologia negócio para colocar de pé
uma solução que contribua para resolver
esse tipo de problema
problemas reais que vão evitar que
jovens como ele sofresse as complicações
do diabetes e outras doenças crônicas
por exemplo descobri que ele também não
está sozinho
segundo a oms organização mundial da
saúde 400 milhões de pessoas hoje têm
diabetes
muitas não sabem que têm não tem
diagnóstico e é outras doenças como
hipertensão e doenças cardiovasculares
fazem parte desse grupo das crônicas não
transmissíveis e não transmissíveis dcnt
são responsáveis por 72% das mortes no
brasil e matam 16 milhões de pessoas
todos os anos
foi com esse contexto com esse com essas
informações de pano de fundo que eu não
sócios felipe dias e reunimos uma equipe
que hoje trabalha na plataforma saúde
que é um negócio social que surgiu desse
ambiente dentro da favela e tecnologias
portáteis para democratizar o acesso a
serviços
faço de saúde na atenção primária como
exames capilares de sangue como a
leucemia colesterol e triglicerídeos que
podem ser feitos por exames com
equipamentos portáteis junto com o
software de gestão de dados clínicos e
avaliações de risco que tem um algoritmo
que combina todos os indicadores já era
um resultado que o grau de risco do
indivíduo desenvolver doença crônica
além disso tem um módulo de
acompanhamento onde o paciente recebe a
alertas e push notifications pelo
aplicativo e também via sms para
estimular a adoção de hábitos mais
saudáveis porque é fundamental que o
indivíduo entendo o que ele precisa
fazer para que aí sim ele adote o hábito
e de fato haja impacto na mitigação de
risco de desenvolver essas doenças
nos últimos dois anos eu e meu sócio
filipe a nossa equipe a gente vem
trabalhando para construir uma cultura é
pautada em alicerces que a gente
acredita como valores e que a gente tem
certeza que estão contribuindo para que
a gente se prepara para gerar ainda mais
impacto no futuro eu quero compartilhar
um pouco desses pilares com vocês hoje
eles são o propósito a equidade eo
excesso de protagonismo por estar nesse
meio de de empreendedorismo digital
inclusive e até de negócios sociais
é importante falar do senso de propósito
porque essa é uma delas
apesar de a gente ter múltiplos fatores
para determinar o que é um sucesso e
também seus objetivos de um negócio é o
o os critérios para determinar o sucesso
eles são quase que seus comum e é
fundamental tratar do propósito viagem
de propósito porque a gente vê muitos
empresários que começa um negócio
pensando só em ganhar dinheiro só uma
recompensa de curto prazo que é muito
frágil mas a conversa de curto prazo ela
quando o empreendedor ele se vê diante
de uma dificuldade que são muitas que a
gente não consegue mapear momento que
toma a decisão de abrir uma empresa
ele se não tiver resiliência que essa
habilidade cair levantar de passar pelas
adversidades e ele está sendo levado por
dinheiro isso é muito frágil antes de ir
para a área de negócios eu queria ser
músico contendo para os canarinhos de
petrópolis na cidade natal e eu hoje faz
um paralelo uma associação muito grande
então principalmente à luz do propósito
entre a carreira do artista ea do
empreendedor
artista ele é o cara que ele é movido
por um propósito uma paixão mesmo que
ninguém compra sua tela mesmo que
ninguém compre o seu quadro a sua música
ele continua trabalhando naquilo porque
ele tem uma motivação interna que faz
com que ele continue seguir adiante
apesar das adversidades apesar de as
pessoas não chegaram que ele enxerga ou
não ouvir o que ele vê assim como
empreendedor que muitas vezes é um
visionário que tem uma ideia e que
apesar de todos os as circunstâncias
externas em contra ele têm resiliência
seguir adiante
o segundo pilar ele trata da equidade
que foi o conceito começou com platão na
grécia antiga e depois foi desenvolvido
por aristóteles onde ele chegou a essa
conclusão nesta definição que coloca o
conceito de eqüidade inclusive acima da
igualdade onde a eqüidade é de fato a
combinação de igualdade e de justiça
onde ele diz que é a equidade a correção
da lei quando ela é deficiente em razão
da sua universalidade ou seja gente
precisa tratar os iguais de forma igual
os desiguais de forma desigual
o exemplo idas das paraolimpíadas onde
cada modalidade tem diferentes níveis
de acordo com grau de deficiência do
indivíduo para garantir que as pessoas
possam competir de forma igual e justo
ou seja equânime com equidade
o censo da equidade
eu tive uma passagem uma um aprendizado
que eu tive quando era mais jovem quando
cantava no coral canarinhos que eu quero
compartilhar com vocês também
eu fui a uma eu fui uma viagem que era
muito longa e imagino um coral de
meninos cantores são 40 crianças alguns
jovens e o líder uma falha disse o
professor de música na época ea gente
tem vários problemas durante a viagem
quando a gente chegou lá estava todo
mundo morrendo de fome eo pneu furou o
motorista se perdeu quando a gente
chegou no garante deveria chegar
estamos todos fartos e cansados e eu
percebi que o morales toma uma decisão
que pra mim hoje eu leio como uma lição
de liderança e de equidade
primeiro que ele garantiu que todos os
menorzinhos se servissem primeiro é
claro é esperado que tanto fisicamente
como psicologicamente os jovens adultos
os atores possam reagir melhor a esses
problemas de ficar tanto tempo sem comer
etc
então pra mim aquilo foi uma lição é
simples um exemplo que ilustra como a
gente precisa estar atento e sensível ea
perceber essas lições do dia a dia e
segundo uma lição de dança porque
mostrou que ele além de se garantir que
todos os jovens se servissem primeiro
foi o último a ser vi isso pra mim me
deu uma lição de que o líder é sempre o
primeiro nos deveres mas nem sempre o
primeiro dos direitos ea equidade esse
conceito de eqüidade
ele também é aplicado na na própria área
da saúde onde o voto hoje a gente vê ele
é um princípio doutrinário do próprio
sus ea gente vê esse reflexo nas
próprias classificações de risco onde te
garante que o indivíduo que por exemplo
é só ficou alguma doença grave ou sofre
com algum problema uma fratura por
exemplo chega um hospital ou uma unidade
de saúde e vai passar na frente vai ser
atendido antes do indivíduo que tem uma
gravidade ou urgência menor do que ele
mesmo que esse indivíduo tenha chegado
muito antes similar a uma matriz guti de
gravidade urgência tendência na
administração
eu acredito que esse conceito de
eqüidade ele precisa ser muito bem
pensado por nós empreendedores
ano passado tive na cúpula das américas
que foi o encontro entre os chefes de
estado os delegados dos países membros
das américas e o tema da reunião foi
prosperidade com eqüidade ou seja todo
esse pessoal se reuniu para discutir uma
agenda de propostas que permitam que
dentro da esfera da iniciativa pública
sejam criados mecanismos para garantir
que os empreendedores que são os maiores
empregadores do mundo possam criar um
padrão pavimentar o caminho para que
todos cresçam a equipe seja estimular
todos cresçam com com oportunidades
justas e iguais ou seja trabalhar o
princípio da equidade dentro do ambiente
da criação do negócio
eu acho que a eqüidade está muito mais
relacionada muito mais associada ao ao
ponto de vista da solidariedade do que
da qualidade por exemplo de qualidade é
vertical é de cima para baixo
organização ajudando a outra de forma
assistencialista
enquanto a solidariedade ela busca essa
reunião é essa essa relação horizontal
que olha outro no olho e é isso que a
gente busca trazer para dentro da
plataforma saúde à luz da equidade
o terceiro e último ponto que eu quero
compartilhar com vocês sobre o censo de
protagonismo
e voltando à grécia é protagonismo vem
do grego protagonistas e quer dizer o
primeiro que vai a batalha 1º que vai à
guerra o primeiro que é dada a cada
etapa que não tem medo de correr riscos
eu acho que essa peça é o princípio da
do protagonismo tá de forma intrínseca e
nós seres humanos
a gente não tem uma referência de uma
gravura do homem das cavernas e não
procurar emprego por exemplo das câmeras
não quero que vai caçar vai descobrir
como é que faz fogo vai proteger a sua
família vai encontrar comida de alguma
maneira vai garantir com a subir com os
meus próprios da sua sobrevivência
eu acho que a gente precisa pensar no
ponto do do ponto de vista do
protagonismo não só como empreendedor
como gerente de projetos ou de produto e
de uma empresa mas também como a gente
pode aplicar o conceito é no próprio
produto que vai interagir com o usuário
final
a plataforma saúde por exemplo a gente
desenvolver software gestão de lado
clínico que entrega
esses resultados em uma escala de cores
para facilitar o entendimento pessoa
diferente grau de instrução
a gente pensa em todos os detalhes do
design desde como a gente chama os
botões aplicativos é a minha saúde ou
sua saúde para que o indivíduo se sinta
de fato empoderado entenda que é ele que
tem que cuidar do seu corpo que tem que
prestar atenção ao seu cuidado com a
saúde a gente tem essa cultura de que a
saúde
a gente cuida do hospital e está
creditada ao cuidado com o médico os
profissionais de saúde
na verdade a gente como empresa acredita
que a saúde ea doença que a gente cuida
do hospital em uma unidade de saúde da
saúde mesmo a gente cuida nosso dia a
dia e todo o software é construído
pensando no design que vai facilitar que
essa mensagem chegue às pessoas ted é
uma planta tecnologia entretenimento e
design de design então como que a gente
como empreendedor pode pensar um design
que vai facilitar para que pessoas
diferentes grau de instrução de alguém
que não tem ensino infantil completo até
um doutor
entenda o que está acontecendo com o
corpo delas e é esse ponto do
protagonismo ele ele me faz voltar
àquela questão anterior das reflexões
sobre que tipo de causa a gente estaria
disposto a se comprometer com
próximos cinco dez anos ou a nossa vida
toda para resolver problemas que as
pessoas sentem na pele de verdade quando
comecei a fazer essa reflexão voltando
ao caso de dodô presidente kennedy
eu aprendi muita coisa sobre mim pra
pedir a chegar mais perto dos meus
valores através dessas perguntas é
preciso compartilhar as coisas com vocês
e eu também aprendi muita coisa sobre
empreendedorismo sobre aprender de
verdade a gente que realmente coloca a
mão na massa faz as coisas acontecerem e
eu aprendi por exemplo que dinheiro é
uma motivação muito frágil que a gente
um empreendedor e precisa ser movido por
um propósito
aprendi também que a ideação tem idéias
e sonhar é muito legal mas também não é
suficiente porque sonhar inspira mas
executar que transforma a mensagem que
queria deixar para vocês é que vocês e
todos nós sejamos pessoas que executam
que pensa na eqüidade e que sejam
protagonistas com propósito essa tudo
obrigado